is it possible to work at a mass torture
and execution signed without noticing
what's going on the German judge
presiding over the trial of a former
concentration camp secretary says it's
simply beyond all imagination nearly 80
years after the crimes were committed
the now 97 year old woman has been found
guilty of aiding and abetting the murder
of more than ten thousand people in the
stutoff camp she was given a two-year
suspended sentence because the judges
were convinced she knew about and
through her work deliberately supported
the killings this is likely to be one of
the last trials related to the Nazis
World War II crimes
97 year oldner was sentenced as a
juvenile because she was just 18 when
she began working as a secretary at the
shutoff concentration camp in 1943
she was given a two-year suspended
sentence
this is in line with what The plaintiffs
Wanted
the victims I represent wanted her to be
pronounced guilty they were not
interested in any sort of punishment
it was about proof of complicity in this
monstrous number of murders
the victims were gassed shot or died
from Hunger cold or illness they
perished in forced marches or after they
were transported to Auschwitz
it's easy to say she was just a
secretary but her role in the heart of
the Camp's bureaucracy was significant
the verdict passed after a 40-day trial
may sound lenient to some
but many of the victims feel that
justice has finally been served
or we can now talk to our political
correspondent Simon young Simon tell us
more about emgat feigner and her role at
the Soto concentration camp
yes she worked in the office of the camp
commandant from June 1943 to April 1945
and the prosecution successfully argued
that she was an accessory in the murder
of more than ten thousand people because
she couldn't have done that job without
being aware of mass executions that were
happening but also of the systematic
starvation and maltreatment of prisoners
and that by her work she had effectively
helped to ensure the the operation of
the stuttoff death camp now as we've
said she's now a 97 year old woman she
appeared in court sitting in a
wheelchair although last year at the
beginning of the trial she did actually
go fugitive for a short time seeming to
try to evade Justice before she was
picked up by the police for a long time
during the trial she remained silent
didn't say anything but she did
eventually manage to say this I'll just
quote I'm sorry about everything that
happened I regret that I was inched at
half at the time she got a two-year
suspended sentence after those crimes
that she was complicit in
um
criticized as too lenient why why only
two years and why a suspended sentence
yeah uh well the as we've said uh aim
God Faulkner was uh tried uh before a
juvenile court because she was only 18
or 19 years old uh at the time of these
crimes uh and that has an effect on the
sentencing in fact a two-year suspended
jail term was what the prosecution had
asked for and although that has been
criticized by some of the uh plaintiffs
in this case and indeed some have said
well it might have been possible to
insist on a longer jail term I don't
think anyone ever expected that she
would actually be sent to jail many
experts have just said well you know
that wouldn't really serve any purpose
she is 9 37 now why has it taken so long
for her to stay in trial
yes this woman was a civilian and for a
long time such people
were not considered
particularly culpable at least in the
criminal sense by comparison of course
with uh with uh uniform wearing uh Nazis
so after the end of the second world war
of course there were the Nuremberg
trials at which some high-ranking Nazis
were convicted and later on in the 60s
there were some more trials but the
general story sadly is that uh I think
of Germany to a degree lost interest in
Prosecuting these people particularly
people who are lower down in the
Machinery that all changed in 2011 with
the trial of former SS Camp guard John
Demian York who as it were despite only
being a guard was convicted and since
then there have been a number of Trials
and convictions of uh odds and as if you
like small cogs in the machine
but of course very few of these people
have actually gone to jail either
because it were in several cases the
defendants died during their trials how
has this trial been perceived here in
Germany
yeah I think there are those who will
look at this and uh feel that uh you
know what purpose does it serve to send
a 97 year old woman or to pass sentence
on her and as people may say that she
didn't have a very important role and
you know they'll feel that it's slightly
irrelevant but I think the mainstream
view is certainly that this does send an
important message it does have a value
it gives the victims and relatives
survivors such as there are still a few
of them some sense at least that justice
has been done and it sends to Future
Generations I think the message that
human rights crimes and abuses will not
be got forgotten and perpetrators will
be brought to Justice where that's at
all possible so if this were the end of
the road to justice for the Nazis
victims all in all how is Germany fared
and holding the people behind the
atrocities accountable
yes well it would take a while to sum
all that up but uh historians do say
there were perhaps about 200
000 uh Nazi perpetrators who committed
crimes during the second World War uh
there have been less than uh 7 000
convictions of such people uh since the
war so it's a pretty small proportion I
think you can say and the sad thing is
that it would be a much higher number if
trials like this one had begun much
earlier and had been prosecuted more
systematically
political correspondent Sam young thank
you so much
I'm joined Now by a man who's often been
described as the last Nazi Hunter
is the director of the Seaman visa
center in Israel and has helped bring
many Nazi war criminals to trial thank
you very much for being with us now a
German court has just convicted an
elderly woman of having contributed to
the murder of over 10 000 people in a
Nazi concentration camp she was given a
two-year sentence a suspended sentence I
know you've been following this trial do
you consider that sentence appropriate
it's the best sentence that we could
have gotten because she's being tried in
a juvenile court that's part of the
problem here
and in a certain respect the suspended
sentence is absolutely absurd because
the suspended sentence means that the
sentence will only be implemented if the
person repeats the crime and obviously
she's not about to repeat the crime nor
is Bruno day who served as a watchtower
Garden stood off and also got a
subsidian acceptance
during this trial the defendant remained
largely silent until the end when she
said quote that she was sorry for
everything that happened what do you
make of that apology
to my mind it's absolutely ludicrous
because if what she apologizing for she
didn't know that people were being
murdered and stood off
in our report uh just now we saw a
holocaust Survivor who accused the
German Judiciary of doing nothing for
many years and then only going after
what he called the small fish do you
share that assessment
listen that's that's a truthful
assessment but what he doesn't know
apparently is that helper Paul Verna
Hopper who was the second comic doctor
and who was uh first in Superior was
convicted was and wasn't incarcerated
for nine years in West Germany
some were saying so generally it's true
in other words his statement in general
is true that many of the big fish got
away and these people are minor figures
but listen the passage of time in low
weight diminishes the guilt of the
killers
the old age is not a excuse or a reason
why people should not be brought to
Justice and this is what we owe we owe
to the victims and their families that
any person who was involved in these
crimes uh you know should be should pay
for them and I could just point out that
in the previous trial of of Bruno day
also served Institute the judge uh and
and Maya Goring gave a brilliant verdict
in which you explained she ripped the
pieces all the arguments against these
trials in other words because of the
advanced stage of the defendant the time
that passed the fact that more serious
senior people of a senior rank were not
brought to Justice and she basically
said in in crimes of a tragedy like the
Holocaust there's no such thing as a
small car
right so some 80 years have passed now
um some are saying this may be the last
trial of its kind do you think that's
the case
listen over 40 years ago a book was
already written about this I think it
was about the schwamberger trial the
first trial in unified Germany and the
the title was the last Nazi I could tell
you that more than a hundred Nazi war
criminals were convicted in the interim
so I wouldn't run or rush to call this
the last trial I know for a fact that we
at the recenter Center are busy trying
to find as survivors from the ravensburg
the Ravens Brook excuse me uh camps in
Northern Germany who can testify against
a person who served as a god both in the
men's camp and in the women's camp and
is scheduled to be brought to Justice in
the coming months and and there are more
additional investigations going on so
your work continues
um you have spent much of your life
helping to bring Nazi war criminals to
trial looking back at those years how
would you describe Germany's efforts to
confront its Nazi
until 14 years ago
in order to prosecute a Nazi war
criminal in the federal republic you had
to prove that that person had committed
a specific crime against a specific
victim and actually to know the name of
the victim and there and that their
motivation was racial hatred
how could you prove a thing like that
thank God two lawyers who worked at the
center at the central office for the
clarification of Nazi war crimes Thomas
Walter and Kirsten getzer were able to
convince Kurt shrim who's the director
to change the policy and bring people
who were in lesser roles to trial and
accuse them not of murder but of
accessory to murder
and that was actually because of what
happened to the platters of 9 11
the attack on the Twin Towers in New
York who were living in Hamburg and the
German Judiciary correctly wanted to
bring these people to justice but with
the exception of Muhammad Atta who
actually flew one of the planes and was
a suicide bomber the others didn't pull
the trigger but they helped carry out
this terrible crime and by accusing them
of accessory to Justice they could be
brought to Justice and I'm assuming that
they're still in jail at this point
so are you saying that there has been
improvements in terms of the at least
the legal code and going after the Nazi
war criminals in Germany
no question
change has been very very dramatic
if the Germans in that changed the
requirements to bring Nazis to Justice
there wouldn't have been a single one of
these seven trials
okay uh Ephraim sorov director of the
Siemens Center in Israel thank you very
much for talking with us
you're welcome